okay welcome back uh today we're going
to talk about we're going to do the lab
for chapter nine that is uh the chapter
on support Vector
machines um and as usual you know we'll
we have some imports that and we have
some new Imports so uh today we're
talking about support Vector machines in
particular support Vector classifiers so
that's what this SVC stands for there
are other estimators support Vector
regression that and other things that we
were not going to talk about so that's
the main uh estimat
that we'll use from pych learn today uh
we the other thing we're going to do is
compare uh classifiers using this an Roc
curve and so there's a a nice way to
plot an Roc curve um for a given
estimator that we'll use from Psychic
learn and finally we wrote a little
helper function to sort of display some
of the boundaries of uh support Vector
uh the support Vector classifiers that
we'll use that will help us visualize
what these things um how these things
work okay okay um so we're going to use
uh our support vector classifier and
let's just make a toy little data set
here so I'm not going to dwell on the
the code we Ed to make it for us we're
going to look at the the color the the
the points today so we're going to start
off with a case where um the two classes
are not very well separated or they
they're not actually separable in this
case um and fit a classifier to that to
see what kind of support points we get
and how the the support uh changes a
little bit as we change the the cost
parameter that's the main parameter in
support Vector
classifier okay so here's how we fit a
support Vector classifier uh we have to
give it a cost parameter and if you
remember in the class uh we discussed um
how that cost parameter plays the the
higher the cost uh the um the the more
support vectors we have and the The
Wider the market margin is um the CERN
there's also this argument here kernel
and we'll see we're going to use a
linear kernel here that means that the
boundaries are going to be you know
determined by linear functions uh there
are other kernels the most one of the
most commonly used kernel which we'll
see later is the radial basis function
kernel also a gaussian kernel so this
these are the two main arguments you
have to choose when fitting a support
Vector
classifier okay so again it's a psychic
learn estimator so we fit it to the same
way and we can predict the same
way so here's the plot the function we
made this function plot svm that takes
you know a a feature Matrix and an
outcome and a fitted classifier and
plots the decision boundaries as well as
the support points so in this svm linear
there's information about what points
are used as the support points and we've
labeled those with a plus here I see
change colors on this
the the Reds have become greens now yes
yeah that's a bit unfortunate uh that is
likely be oh well I didn't replot them
it plotted them itself yeah yes that's
all right
yes okay so um so what we see here is
this the decision boundary it is linear
for this linear classifier um and these
points here these are points within the
margin um and these are the points that
are or that are sort of on the wrong
side of the margin they they Mark here
with a plus so these these here should
be green and these here should be blue
um okay and they're about uh 25 points
there I'm not exactly
sure so we're going to change the cost
parameter
um
0.1 and actually oh I think I misspoke
before there there is a paramet so yes
to my to my defense there are a few
different let me say how did I misspeak
before
please go no I I see it now it is the
cost so the cost um if there's lower
cost in being on the other side of the
margin you'll you'll you'll allow more
points on the on the other side and
that's yes I was hoping we could just
let that one slip by but anyway you
picked up and yes well I mean so the the
smaller the cost the more support points
you get yes you pay less of a price for
being on the wrong side of the margin
yes and I would my you know flight def
there's some people parameterize cost
inversely so yeah and then I would have
been okay in that case but it matters
actually how how it's parameterized and
so with this cost the smaller one means
there's smaller cost being on the wrong
side so it's easier okay and what we're
meant to see here is that there are more
support points they're about the same
number of support points but there are
some regions like this region here that
have come in and if you go look at the
margin let's see this point here uh must
not be in the other plot let's take a
look that's the farthest one see that
point is not is not across the margin
when I Ed at 10 so in a sense the
smaller the cost the more points the
support points you got and that means
the solutions somehow more regularized
because you're using more of the
training data to determine the
orientation of the the margin of the
decision boundary that's right like the
yes the slope of this line here is
determined by somehow averaging the
points of the these two different the
points on each side exactly yeah so if
you only have a few um then it will be
less
robust okay so since it's a linear
classifier you can actually find the the
the the direction of the the decision
boundary and that of course would be not
this direction here but it would be this
direction here sort of that you can use
to to determine the
classifier okay well we have this tuning
parameter C uh we had used two values
before 0.1 and
10 why don't we see if we can find a
good one
automatically well this is you know this
is what one of the nice things that
abouts could learn of course is that if
you have an estimator um you can pick a
cross validation method like fivefold
cross validation or or train train test
split and then you can use this grid
search CV to try and um tune that
parameter so the parameters that we're
going to search over are given by the
second argument and here this is a
dictionary with the argument C uh being
uh the possible values that we'll so
we'll look at C from .01 to 100 fitting
the grid search yeah and by the way we
we saw the cross validation in action in
in the labs for chapter six as well
that's right this that's where we
encountered this grid sech
TV and so it's decid it's picked the
best parameters uh and the cost being
one so and like in in chapter six the
best estimator is stored as grid.
bestore estimator uncore so we can use
that to predict new methods going
[Music]
forward okay so let's take a look at how
this Choice was made we as we saw in in
chapter six the grid um uh computes the
test score as a function of the
different parameters and we can see here
here's the mean test score in this case
accuracy and uh actually although it
picked this value 0.1 here that's the
index uh corresponding to 0.1 there are
actually four different Val cost
parameters that gave us the same
classification so it's not necessarily a
very um you know very clearcut choice
that point one that one is the best but
so since small C's correspond to more
regularization it's it's choosing the
most regularized um solution
um that gives the same among the same
yes errors yeah
yeah okay and uh if we want to evaluate
you know this this estimator again the
grid. bestest estimator is the one that
was tuned by grid search TV we can
generate new data from the same
distribution and and uh compute um
compute a confusion Matrix so here we're
just going to generate some new x's and
y's using the same data generating uh
mechanism as above and uh we'll compute
the predictions using our best estimator
and compare them to our uh actual
labels um and here our classifier got
about 70% accurate which is pretty close
to the 74% that the uh yeah and we only
used you know 20 points we could have
used more it might have gotten even
closer to
74% Okay so if we instead of taking the
best estimator we choose one that was
not a parameter that was not chosen to
be best like something very small um so
this is this is
uh quite
regularized right no I'm getting the
index wrong again uh uh here it's 60% on
this data set so you know it did seem to
make a reasonable choice at choosing one
at least one seems better than
0.001
okay let's uh also we're going to look
at an example where we can linear
linearly separate the data so here we've
just moved the means of the red and the
Blue Points a little bit further
apart and
um if we if we uh fit the support back
machine we should see that um it should
be separable um and here we put a very
large cost here so this uh if if the
cost is not is I wonder if any cost
um if for very high cost it should it
should pick the separable solution but
uh for low cost actually off the top of
my head I'm not sure if it would pick
the separable solution no it wouldn't it
would still allow yeah more support
points
yeah okay and here we can see that this
is a case where there's a very few
support points compared to the 20 or so
we had before we had three um
so if we sort of change the the this
class a little bit or this class a
little bit these points here that are
the support points are likely to move
and hence the uh the plane as we
discussed before formed by these support
points might also be quite variable yeah
yeah and of course there are many
separating hyperplanes here so we'd
expect this to vary a lot as we change
training and test data as as as
statisticians when we look at this plot
we see that the the the decision
boundaries determin here by just three
data points and so that makes you
suspect it's not that robust right
because these are data points are on the
boundaries of each of their classes and
you know so they as Jonathan said change
the data a little bit and that can
change orientation of the the decision
boundary dramatically yeah and I mean
there's are also as like this is one
separating hyperplane but there are many
here
right yes
exactly
okay
[Music]
um
okay so I'm just going to move on to
the the next topic um with and this is
we saw above the uh the linear support
Factor classifier so that's used as
linear decision boundaries um one of the
main uses of support factor classifiers
is for nonlinear boundaries and the way
it does that is using changing this this
kernel argument earlier we used kernel
was linear
other popular choices are polinomial or
uh radial basis function kernel so the
radial basis function kernel that's a
gan so it looks something you know like
this and then so under the hood what's
going to happen is there will be each
each point in the two classes will have
a potential little radial basis function
attached to it and the weights we saw
for the linear decision boundary will be
attached to the points um to to
multiplying those bumps we saw before so
in this case the decision boundary is
going to be where some linear
combination of bumps like this bump and
that bump where that's zero so it's
going to be some kind of possibly
complicated shape
um okay so we're going to make a
slightly more complex uh data set here
and by hiding sort of one cloud of one
class
within between two one red class in
between two two blue classes so let's
just take a look at
what our data looks like here oh yeah so
this is one where we wouldn't expect a
linear decision boundary could do very
well right because there's blue anyway
we cut through the red there's going to
be blue on either side of it so using
this radial basis function uh if you you
know abstractly we could put a big bump
here a big bump here with positive
weights and then maybe a bump down here
with negative weights and that might
separate the classes pretty well um it's
not exactly doing one or two bumps like
that but it's doing it's doing some
linear combination of bumps to try and
make uh a good boundary in a nonlinear
space that's a weird data set isn't it
yes yeah I wonder why we chose that one
uh well I think to make it more
complicated because the next picture
looks really good
yes okay
um so we we're going to do a training
and test split to evalu bit later and
we're going to fit our svm on on the
training data so um here is the part
where we actually fit the S the support
Factor machine we give it this kernel
argument as radial basis function we
still have this cost and then there's
this gamma parameter and this gamma
parameter sort of determines the size of
the bumps uh not necessarily the height
but really the width so I've just made
one more so as you change gamma you'll
get different sizes like that and you
should check the documentation whether
you know the radial basis function looks
like e to the minus gamma x^2 / 2 that's
going to disappear whether gamma is
above or e- x^2 / 2 gamma down there and
that will make a difference as how you
vary gamma whether it makes a bigger one
or smaller
one
okay so let's see what happened ah look
at that oh wow that did really well yeah
it must always do really well right it
doesn't always to oh that's too bad yes
so we did pick a data set for which uh
you know some nonlinear method like the
radial basis function will will produce
a nice plot um you know obviously any
particular method is not going to work
well in every case but we're trying to
illustrate uh how you can use the radial
basis function to make a nonlinear
boundry and here it you know it did it
did relatively well and again these
these points here uh indicate the
support vectors so the decision boundary
uh is a linear combination of those
bumps and it has a weight for each of
the these points here adding the bumps
with those weights makes a function on
the plane and this decision boundary is
really the zero set of that function so
when it's positive let's say We'll
classify as blue which was originally
red and when it's negative we'll
classify as as blue yeah the the support
points aren't as intuitive in this
picture as it was in the in the linear
one no yeah it's not clear why we have
these far points they're they're and
that's because this there 's a linear
separation in in a higher dimensional
space and we're only seeing some sort of
the two-dimensional picture here yeah
yeah
okay um so let's see again we can change
this cost parameter uh so if we increase
the cost parameter uh that should be um
we'd expect to see fewer support points
as we did in the linear case and
actually with a quite high value here we
have gotten rid of a lot these support
points around here uh and and you're
going to get more Wiggly Solutions now
because it's what it's trying to do is
not misclassify any of the training data
so it's going to make its decision
boundary wrap around to this an example
there's no mistakes there's a little
tiny Island if we compare that to the
previous one it's it's considerably
smoother um it doesn't have any little
Islands so over footing in a case like
this
yes so let's see what
the uh grid search thinks is the best
parameter so now we're going to look in
example we'll use the grid search CV
again but our radial basis function
support Vector machine has two
parameters a cost and a gamma and we're
going to use the grid surch CV function
as we have in other examples to find the
two the the best parameters now one
difference in this example is that we
have two parameters so the argument we
give for the grid of values is a
dictionary with two entries one for the
cost and one for gamma but other than
that it's an estimator that we fit and
it still Returns the best parameters but
now there are two parameters in the
dictionary because we had two grids a
grid of cost and a grid of gamas to
search over so this is practical for
small grids um and simple estimators if
you have many parameters of course this
is going to be a lot of estimators to
fit and that might take a
while okay um so it tells us cost one
and Gamma point5 is the best estimator
and we're going to evaluate the accuracy
of this best estimator on our test data
and take a look at the decision
boundary okay so
um we we produce our predictions on the
test data you know as we always do we'
stored the best estimator as bestore svm
and we make a confusion Matrix as we had
in we on chapter 4 and it does quite
well it does has about 88% accuracy here
let's take a look at the the decision
bound
it got a little push down in this file
here but if we look at this one it looks
pretty smooth similar to the one we saw
um our first set of parameters and
perhaps has a few fewer support vectors
on the outskirts but it definitely looks
smoother than the very highly flexible
one the with a very high cost looks
really
good